il ya je pense à parallèle qu'on peut
faire avec les biotechnologies dans les
années 70 les biologistes ont réalisé
qu'ils pouvaient commencer à modifier le
génome d'êtres vivants ce qu'on appelait
à l'époque l'adn recombinant
on appelle ça génie génétique maintenant
et ça a conduit les biologistes de
l'époque à se réunir et à réfléchir les
questions à dire qu'est ce qu'on va se
permettre de faire et quels types de
deux mesures de sécurité valeur pâton
prendre pour éviter que par exemple
quelqu'un crée une super virus qui
illuminait l'humanité ou utiliser ça
comme arme ou peut-être construire des
des concevoir des sous humains ou des
surhumains et c'est donc aussi interdit
de faire certaines choses comme par
exemple de modifier le code génétique
humain pour et produire des humains
modifié on s'est interdit de faire
d'autres choses comme utiliser ça dans
les armes biologiques et autres il ya
des idées des accords internationaux
pour pour ça alors on en est pas on ne
naît pas à ce niveau là avec un sonar
officiel on sens que c'est pendant pas
potentiellement aussi dangereux en tout
cas certainement pas pour l'instant et
certainement pas pour les décennies qui
viennent mais c'est quelque chose auquel
il faut réfléchir il faut pas bien sûr
ne pas jouer avec le feu et réfléchir
avant que le avant que le problème ne se
pose de manière urgente
parce qu'il ya plusieurs enjeux sociaux
autour de l'intelligence artificielle
il ya des questions de l'emploi mais une
question dont on parle moins c'est la
question de l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle pour début
peut-être qu'on pourrait questionner
manière éthique
donc on va évidemment il y avait la
question d'une session militaires qui
étaient discutés dans les médias mais
moi j'ajouterais là-dedans l'utilisation
d'un épisode artificiel pour manipuler
les gens c'est déjà le cas par exemple
la publicité le manipule mais ça risque
d'aller encore plus au fur et à mesure
que l'ordinateur à plus d'informations
sur nous et puis est plus fort dans son
intelligence et en général je pense
qu'il faut qu'on réfléchisse
comme pour n'importe quelle technologie
puissante le nucléaire qu'est ce qu'on
fait ce qu'on veut bien faire avec
là je parle pas de limite à la recherche
je parle des limites à l'utilisation